Hutch. Hutch had some weird going on with Josiah. People like
basically saying um I don't know. Josiah's doing weird, right?
But I don't know why that would be the case.
Let me take a look at this.
I think this is around where the the time stamp should be. Let
me look into this. So Hutch gets uh Hutch is watching some Destiny
stream about Josiah. One second here. Let me unmute. particular
thinks but just
based on what I've observed I think he very clearly thinks that
we have crossed we have crossed a a particular threshold and
now that we're past that threshold
he's entertaining
um hold on let me go back to here >> I I did pre-w
Yeah yeah I know I know I know but I'm just I'm looking for um
looking for this Destiny's chat was psychotic yesterday during
the Josiah combo watch along. I managed about 15 minutes reading
Hutch is controlled ops a grifter Republican and other
>> Sorry, I wanted to see what put him on to this. So,
there's a message from his chat just saying like, "Oh, go look
at >> Republican and Other Delusions. All right, let's
get into it. I I I did pre-watch some of this, so I'm not going
to lie to you guys. >> Let's get into it. Um,
let's do something real quick here. Let's restructure this screen.
We're going to do display capture. Um, what's the date today?
>> 10:21. 10:21.
Wait, hold on. >> What is he doing? Okay. Okay. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. He's setting stuff up. >> Oh, he wants to see
the chat messages.
Uh, Josiah has been weirdly hostile/ irritated towards Hutch
for the past couple of months. Felt like every disagreement Hutch
had, Josiah took it as a you're just giving me a hard time right
now.
Uh, I think Josiah I haven't heard an argument Josiah's had with
Hutch that isn't just Josiah saying the same positions I've seen
him have for like two years. Like the biggest argument I thought
they had if if I'm not mistaken was something along the lines
of Hutch wants to critique Hassan and Josiah feels like punching
left is useless, right? And they've talked through that. I think
some other stuff around how to cut, you know, unhelpful pieces
out of the Democrat coalition. Josiah basically says I never
punch left, right? It's the same position he's had for like two
and a half years. Has always defended, has always had this position.
I don't I don't know. You'd have to be like
horribly uninformed, like terribly misinformed or lying to have
this opinion, right? You just would have to know nothing about
Josiah >> like that. Why don't we do it like that? I do
find the whole situation like pretty remarkable
>> in that. Here's what it probably is. Oh, hold on. I
paused the music cuz I want to listen to Hutch. So, Tequila Sunset
says, "I think Josiah's biggest reason for leaving was that his
channel's main content is actually successful and he only gets
200 concurrens from li for live and learn." I think it's it's
like more complex than that. I think I think you'll see Josiah
hop on these streams and be totally fine hopping on these streams.
I do really believe that Josiah probably doesn't want a commitment
that isn't making anywhere near as much as like his actual video
content would. It's just the the commitment element, right? where
you have this thing like probably, you know, he'd like to go
maybe for a date that night or something like just set up your
real life. It's I don't even think he'll stream less. I feel
like it it could be entirely possible in my head.
>> Oh, I'm saying I'm not saying he's streaming. I I said
streaming. He could end up on streams less, but I don't even
know if he will. I feel like he likes hopping on
feel like he likes hopping on random streams sometimes
and that's probably all he's I mean that's probably all he's
looking for, right? I'll hop on a stream once in a while and
give my opinion, sharpen it, argue with somebody if I want to
argue and then I'll go back to doing my own content.
That's that's how I feel about it. Oh, apparently there's a tweet.
One second. Oh, sure. Sure. I saw this. Yeah, I I basically read
this and I'm I'm saying what I think it is regardless of what
Hutch said or sorry, Josiah said. I'm literally I'm literally
looking at this and I don't care, right? Um the end of an era.
Join us tonight 7 p.m. this is it. End of live and learn. So
Hutch leaves live and learn. He's not going to be doing that
anymore. Seeing some replies attribute this decision to my last
convo with Hutch, but that's not true. I told Pisco and Hutch
around the time a Connoy left that I was thinking of leaving
too. And I finally made my decision a week ago before that convo
took place. was going to wait till the show to explain my reasons,
but TLDDR: I'm married now. Want to spend more time with my wife.
I want to spend more time with friends and on getting back in
shape. I'm a oneman show, no editor/ staff who cranks out 5day
videos a day, 6 days a week.
So, he does work quite hard. This is something you could possibly
fix with money. I think it's mostly having that. There's something
about committing to a weekly thing that's so much different than
actually spending that time doing the activity. Like if you committed
to going for a run with like a group of friends on Wednesday
nights every week you committed to that weighs on you. It weighs
in your mind so much more heavily than just oh somebody calls
you and says let's go for a run. You end up going twice a week
on a run, right? But it's just like do you want to do it? Do
you want to go at that given time? It's like that commitment
will be something where you can dread it and people don't like
it, right? So, I think given that it's a full-on commitment once
a week to a show, he probably just would rather
I assume he would rather not have the commitment and hop on streams
occasionally if that's what strikes him if that's that's what
strikes his fancy at any given moment.
Seems way more likely to me. But anyway, we'll go back to this.
Oh, yeah. This comment was >> for me. What I've observed
for sure is
that Destiny
has definitely
become
much much much much more blackpilled
in the last like two two three months.
And um I I doubt even his audience would disagree with that.
I'm just making a neutral observation. I mean I have my own judgments.
I don't I have no >> of that but without even getting into
that I think it is safe to say that and I don't want to misrepresent
uh what Destiny thinks but just
>> based on what I've observed I think he very clearly
thinks that we have cross we have crossed a a particular threshold
>> we're playing this is 75 no
>> and now that we're past that threshold
he's entertaining Um, oh, I don't really care. Well, I mean,
do you have a link for that? Kyle Kolinsky said he's hella pissed
at you for straw manning. >> Hold on. I missed the chat
message. There's a $5 donation. Kyle Klinsky said he's hella
pissed at you for straw manning him on yesterday's Kyle and Corin
live stream at 21842
there. Well, I mean, do you have a link for that? Kyle Klinsky
said he's hella you for straw manning him
on yesterday's Kyle and Corin live stream. We We should do one
thing at a time here, but I I don't think I straw manned him.
Um, Kyle and Corin. Uh,
Is it on Corin's world?
>> Um, eight days ago live 13 hours ago.
>> 2182 live. >> Yes, sir. >> Kyle's in the
building. There's people in the building. >> I mean, and
if there if it's happening on Spotify, my guess is it's happening
everywhere. My guess is, you know, Ice Ice may be buying ads
on YouTube that we don't know about. You know what I'm >> So,
like sometimes, you know, there is no mechanism that these companies
to say like, "Fuck you. We don't want your money." You know what
I'm saying? >> Is this the one? Thank you though for the
super.
>> Okay, now discerning viewers will will pick something
up here. Okay, the guy who is saying that Kyle is is annoyed
with Hutch or whatever is the same the guy who donated to Hutch
saying that is the same guy who donated to Kyle says, "Yo, Kyle
Hutch be criticizing your criticisms of Democrats, but they're
good faith and interesting. So, I'd love to see another KKF debate
with him soon." This this guy seems to really be a Hutch fan,
though. like he's not he's not, you know, throwing hutch under
the bus here. He's saying, "Hey, like good criticisms, man. You
should check them out. You should check them out." And then he
comes over to Hutch and he donates and goes, "Hey, Hutch.
Kyle Kyle talks some you bro." Yo, Kyle Hutch be criticizing
your criticism, but they're good faith and interesting. So, I'd
love to see another KKF debate with him soon. Um, so here's my
issue with Hutch that uh he really he really let me down in a
way where like I'm not interested in >> He had he did some
video a while ago. >> Oh. And
>> in the title, I forget exactly what the title was, but
there was a picture of me in the thumbnail with some other people
as well. I forget who else was in it, but it was like me, maybe
Crystal, maybe some other people. And basically,
>> does his podcast host or co-host not look like Mike
Shenoda from uh Lincoln Park? Am I crazy? either in the thumbnail
or the title, the implication was I was arguing like
Democrats and Republicans are the same or like
let me see if I can find what thumbnail he's even talking about.
Does anybody know what thumbnail he's talking about? Uh I haven't
done many
videos on Kyle
been like three. Um he's a useful idiot. No, it's not that one.
>> Wait, no way. Hold on. Hold on. I have to go to Hutch's
YouTube real quick. I just check it out. One second. One second.
Uh, Kyle.
Oh, how that was is right there. How Kyle Klinsky rewrites history
with a soy Kyle face. Right there. Hold on. Let's Let's just
search Kyle here in the in the channel. See what we got. Uh,
he's a useful idiot. Pointing at Kyle. This is shameless. Kyle
Clinsky goes full conspiracy nut on Charlie Kirk.
Chen gets steamrolled in wild debate versus Crystal and Kyle.
Total meltdown. Lefty media reacts to dark Gavin Newsome. Kyle
Klinsky versus Assan. How Kyle Kolinsky rewrites history. Wait,
did he say he'd only done like three videos on Kyle? He's done
a couple. He's done a couple. Okay, he's done a couple. Let's
keep watching. Which one is it? Oh, it's this one here. Okay,
this is what he's talking about.
Wait, can I show all that? Is everything fine with I think so.
Yeah. Okay, it's this one here. Um,
and it's just a >> Oh, I didn't even We didn't even get
that one. This needs to stop.
Uh-oh.
Oh, what would this have been about, too? Like, you could tell
it's a it's a lefty or Palestine thing. Debating the black pill
left with history speaks. Okay. Something like this.
Uh,
>> video the thumbnail is is Anna, Noah Samson, Hassan,
Jenk, and Kyle.
It says this needs to stop. And then the title is quote, "Democrats
and Republicans are the same." I find this to be particularly
funny to be honest with you. Like his problem is um how the thumbnail
was done
because and I don't know if this is like wait is that his problem?
I think it sounded like his problem. Am I crazy? Didn't Kyle
say his problem was literally that Hutch basically implied that
Kyle thinks Democrats and Republicans are the same? Isn't that
his
>> I feel like this is fine to say, but just like
uh privately in DMs. Wait, hold on. Let me let me make sure I'm
remembering that. Was it him? I'm almost positive
that in private we had an exchange where I I think either I I
think what happened was my editor >> Oh, so wait, was it
this time or was it a different time where you made Kyle look
like a complete in your thumbnails?
>> Wait, hang on. Is Is this Is this even what he's referring
to? I So
on YouTube, we play the game for sure.
Mr. Editor Man, he edits the videos, does the thumbnails, the
descriptions, he decides on the title.
Sometimes I'll give my own sort of input on what I like what
framing I think would be best, but he is ultimately in charge
of that and technically has veto power over me.
>> "Nah, that's not true. That's that's literally not true."
Okay. No shot. You could say, "Hey, I let him cook and maybe
there are times where I should pull back or something." But you
have to, as the owner of the channel, as the actual face of the
channel and the talent, you have to take on that ultimately it's
my choice to hire him. It's my choice to employ him. He does
not have full veto power. Assuming that this editor doesn't just
own Hutch's YouTube channel, which would be insane for him to
do this all on a YouTube channel he doesn't own. Could you imagine
if that's what he was doing? That would be that would be crazy.
There's no way that this guy has veto power over him if he is
the owner of the YouTube channel could remove the guy from the
account. That's the ultimate veto power. Okay, that was the way
that we structured this arrangement.
Um, and then you know, we're trying to build the channel up and
if the channel becomes something bigger, then
>> listen, if you're if he was banned from YouTube and
he could say, "Oh, it's some guy who clips on his own channel
and can post whatever he wants and I don't have ownership." Okay,
if that's if that were the case, then he could say that. But
I think even in that case, I I still like
>> I can make comments to Riyle. I don't >> We'll
do like a partnership kind of thing, but
none of that is relevant. I don't even know why I'm going down
on that tangent, but we play the game. So, YouTube, you you know,
we don't do I'd like to think You guys tell me if >> he
He just keeps saying we play the game. We play the game. >> I'm
wrong. I'd like to think we don't do
clickbait.
Like, I don't think I've ever seen Mr. Editor Man and do that.
>> Okay, perfect. So, then say Kyle, you're wrong. you
do think what I said and I'm standing on business. This is Hutch
just he wants to say he's stand he's standing on business but
he doesn't want to upset somebody right like he wants to say
oh well yeah I do think this but he also doesn't want to make
the guy mad well you said something offensive to him it's going
to make him mad
where it's it's marketed as something
but then you that ended up being highly misleading that's not
something that I would be okay with
but we do put some pepper on it and I I am almost positive that
I reached out to Kyle one time before posting a video with him
on the thumbnail
and I think it was maybe around the time that I went on his podcast
and he went on our podcast
and I told him I was like, "Hey, just so you know." And I think
I asked him like, "Are you cool with that?" This is this is always
nice. Are you a are you a whiny like are you a whiny gaping Kyle
or are you cool with that? Hey, Kyle, are you a whiny gaping
or are you cool with that? Are you cool with me like kind of
making fun of you a little bit? And I thought
now I have >> everybody unless it's absurd. Everybody just
says, "Yeah, play the game." But it doesn't mean that you can
just say whatever you want and they're not going to hold it against
you or take it personally at all. You'd have to be a child to
not understand that, right? That somebody can say, "Yeah, I guess
that's fine." And still be like, "Oh, that's kind of weird that
you would do >> Have to look now. I just have to look.
I just want to make sure. >> Rhinox, he said explicitly.
It is not a misleading title.
>> Hey, I dude, did this guy freeze? Okay, in the meantime,
guys, there's a blast.
>> Not quite like that. It was actually uh >> like
engage. >> I don't know. I won't get into super specifics
because they're >> he just realized he didn't he just realized
he didn't really categorize the DMs quite correctly, >> right?
But he had actually uh so when I went on his podcast
um he posted uh he posted a
a video that was like an edited version of our conversation and
the title was like heated debate. Um
I think my face was on the thumbnail or something like that.
And then I wrote I reached out to to him and I like we were like
joking about it and you know he basically said something that
indicates you know
what okay all right I dude heated debate is not something that
implies you don't respect the other person it's not something
that implies anything negative about the other person implies
you had a spirited conversation right that's what it implies
it's not the same why is he or something like that and then I
wrote I reached out to him and I like we were like joking about
it and you know he basically said something that indicates you
know like this is this is the way that it's done on YouTube right
um and I didn't have a problem with that but for some reason
this
which I don't even think was like super clickbait and I I'm not
even sure I remember what's in this video >> if you're
amoral they're not partic
if she won >> okay so it's a conversation with uh history
speaks. I guess >> that I'm confident.
>> Okay, I see. And it must have been me talking about
like the left or something
>> like Democrats and Republicans are. >> Wait, is
the History Speaks History Speaks isn't the super Zionist guy
that like hates Lunar Box, is it? Is that who History Speaks
is? The guy who's like gotten into multiple fights with Lunarbox
cuz he keeps trying to like sweep for Israel. No, that's traveling
that's traveling Israel. Oh, maybe I'm thinking of somebody else.
I don't know who History Speaks is. Maybe. Oh, he is pro Palestine.
Okay. Okay. Opposite. I I'm thinking I'm thinking of traveling
Israel is the guy I was thinking of from the loner guy who's
appeared on some loner box streams. Equally bad or something.
And when I saw that, I was just like, okay, that's literally
just a lie.
I've never I have in fact one of my patented rants that I've
been doing on my show on a regular basis hold on hold on hold
on is is Hutch. There's no way that this is what it is, right?
There's no way that Hutch is was concerned about this thumbnail
or something. This thumbnail, heated debate on Camala's Liz Cheney
strategy published by Secular Talk. This is his debate with Hutch,
right? Debate is with Hutch and Pondering Politics,
Kyle, Crystal and Kyle and Friends on Substack. Follow them.
Right? That can't be what he's talking about in comparing to
his on Kyle, right? His thumbnails of Kyle. Those are absolutely
not close. That's that's wild to compare this
is literally the opposite of that point where I say I don't want
to hear any false equivalence anymore in this era. There is no
false equivalence. Literally the worst Democrat you can find
is better than the best Republican you can find. Like so anybody
who does the false equivalence,
they're just wrong and it's just embarrassingly stupid in this
moment. So, the fact that he basically put in like a title or
a thumbnail that like I was somehow doing the thing that I explicitly
do the opposite of all uh well uh here Kyle is saying, "Dude,
I love that Hutch spent all of that time going, I don't think
we ever really mislead with the titles. I don't think we've ever
done anything like that." And that's exactly Kyle's complaint.
Should have pre-watched the Kyle content
horseshit. They're just wrong and it's just embarrassingly stupid
in this moment. So the fact that he basically put in like a title
or a thumbnail that like I was somehow doing the thing that I
explicitly do the opposite of all the not to so to be fair and
not to like offload blame because ultimately like I'm I'm >> he
already said the editor has veto power over him. There's no way
he's going to say the editor did this and and then also try to
cut try to pull it back and say but ultimately I make the final
decision. He's going to now try to take accountability. Okay.
I'm responsible for what goes up on my channel, but I don't make
the thumbnails. Just like I just don't. And I I guess I figured
like when I saw the thumb >> Oh, dude. Flamster I think
I think Flamster comes around here. So, he sees it. Take accountability,
man. Oh, >> no. because
me and him had had an interaction where we were discussing his
thumbnail which framed the conversation that I had with him as
like this heated debate which it really wasn't but uh
again unless unless Kyle got rid of the unless Kyle dropped the
thumbnail here there's you search for Hutch this is the thumbnail
and title of this debate he did debate on Camala's Liz Cheney
strategy like he's really he's really making a comparison between
these two things right now, guys. These are basically the same
heated debate. Although it's possible that that Hutch reached
out and said, "Hey, this bothers me." And they changed the thumbnail
or something, but the title isn't misleading. I'm sure it was
a debate. He did his, I guess, subjective. I don't know. It's
But you're ascribing a position to Kyle that he explicitly doesn't
have. Very, very, very different concepts. >> You know,
it didn't I don't think it got heated a single time. I think
from that point on I assumed that Oh, there's no way.
Oh, this is brutal. This is This is actually kind of brutal for
Hutch, isn't it?
Like I I try to give Hutch the benefit of the doubt cuz I know
a lot of people don't don't, you know, a lot of people against
Hutch right now. I try to be like more charitable than I would
be in some other cases with him. But this is actually bad. Okay,
this is you might say something like Hutch. Hutch might be considered
something like my boy. Okay, you might think you might you could
think of Hutch as my boy. All right, Hutch is my boy for but
this is bad. Kyle says he totally misrepresented a position.
He took the position I have inverted it and then applied it to
me or his editor did. Right. And Hutch goes, "Yeah, well Kyle
really did a misleading thing, too, when he like uh when he said
our debate was heated, but I don't think it got heated at all."
And I kind of just assumed that that was the game. >> You
know,
that that thumbnail stuff and and slightly clickbaity stuff was
fine, but I guess this was a bridge too far for >> bro.
I'm looking. It's not even comparable. It is not even comparable,
dude. I think his I think his chat might have to point this out
to This is a This is pretty goofy position to take. >> So,
uh Okay. >> [__] time. seemingly every show
these days when I saw that I was like I'm done with him. >> I'm
done with him. So I
>> at Drake he is blaming the backlash from the thumbnail
under the editor when at the end of the day his brand his responsibility.
Um unless he was uh what would you call it? Unless like again
I think if you have like other clipping channels there's there's
something to be said for like fair use or or something along
these lines, right? I think I unfollowed him on Twitter. I unsubscribed
from his channel because it was like like look listen I'm I'm
a reasonable dude but if I feel like a criticism is just flat
dishonest
>> and I'm like I'm not going to waste my time with this.
Like I'm done. I'm out of this. And the other thing is I
>> you know it wasn't even when I look at the branding.
Let me look at it again. Hold on. Was it What was the text on
the screen? I mean maybe you could argue my thumbnail guy did
this. I just I really felt like this this needs to stop is what
it was. What? Had there been something recently that I had reacted
to from him? Right here. Kyle Kinsky broke my heart. What was
this video all about? Forgot already. If you actually were to
care about stuff, campaign on stuff, make an argument, fight,
it wouldn't even be a question if you were going to win or not.
But they've actively made the decision to do nothing, to say
nothing. Okay, guys. The >> uh you can't on one hand say
you had nothing to do with the thumbnail with the thumbnail,
and then on the other hand say you thought it was okay because
of your combo. Hutch is a weasel. Hutch is weasel. >> The idea
that the Democrats right now are not doing anything to fight
this administration is just comically wrong. 2015 is when it
like an entire industry of political content creators exploded
in 2015 and it's just like they get control of Congress. They're
doing a good job with like stifling Donald Trump's agenda. And
then Biden's annated and he delivers the most progressive policy
platform in my life and his numbers just go hit their face and
okay get burned to the ground. He's back on the list. All right,
let's check. I mean, okay, >> to be fair, I guess I explicitly
said, "Let's nuke the bridge." So,
>> well, I really feel like he just doesn't remember any
of that. Oh, this guy. Oh, you know what? I did kind of say this
guy, and we did misrepresent him, and I totally make fun of him
in a bunch of my thumbnails and titles. You know what? I I guess
my bad. I forgot that I totally said this. I really feel like
he falls into the same trap as Destiny where he
>> oh
punches left punches left >> and it's like
>> why did Hassan do this to Hutch? Why did Hassan
shock Kyle Kolinsky into pointing this out about Hutch? That's
so up of Hassan to do. I know that if we follow if we watch enough
of Hassan's VODs, we can prove that it was Hassan who pushed
Kyle to do this. Okay, Hutch, I I believe I believe in you. Okay,
we can scrub through enough of these vods, we'll figure it out.
Why? Why are you >> on the left? >> He's He's center
left. >> Oh, okay. >> So, but in this moment, it's
like, no, seriously, you don't get it. Like, fascism is here.
>> We're watching Trump bomb random fishing
>> Dude, I I love I love that this stream starts with,
"Oh, guys, I think Destiny's really just lost his way. I think
he's really blackpilled." And you know, oh, so Kyle commented
on my stuff and then Kyle eventually gets to Hutch is a piece
of he lied about me and he's like destiny. >> I am just,
oh, there's a lot to unpack there. I'm not going to do another
punch left rant. You guys have heard me say it a thousand times.
Um, you can totally punch left when it makes up a significant
portion of your content. It's probably not great. Like, probably
Um, but honestly, it's good content. All Hutch has to do is say,
"My monetary goals, my drama farming goals far outweigh my political
goals."
If you're honest with yourself about that, I I'm honest about
that, right? If Hutch is honest with himself about that, that's
where he'll be led. That's where he'll understand. That is probably
where I'd say he aligns with Destiny most, right? Destiny's Destiny
building a community, building up his own image, building up
his own ego, his own bank account is far more important than
any political movement he belongs to.
That's fine. That's not necessarily negative, unless you're going
to lie about it. If you're honest about it and you're upfront
about it, then that's totally cool. It's all good, man. >> There's
a lot to unpack there. Like, first of all, questioning my bonafides
of being on the left. >> Well, you said you're center left.
I Hutch would describe himself as center left. No.
Wouldn't Hutch describe himself as center left? Is that not Is
Hutch like, "No, no, no. I'm not center left." Oh, you're obviously
progressive. Okay, maybe that is a big thing that Hutch thinks
he's progressive.
Okay.
Um, do I think Hutch is progressive? I honestly don't know very
much about Hutch's like purely like what positions he'd argue
for on any given like issue. I felt like he was center left based
on his rhetoric. Okay.
Um, with regards to Kyle, I don't think Kyle's saying anything
crazy here. If if you say if you're acting like Okay,
thank you. Okay, hold on. Let me see how I conceive of this.
he is consistently a little more like on the on the neoliberal
side of live and learn. So I see him as center left based on
his sort of polarization away from those people, right? I I don't
think I think he's like on the left of the the spectrum. I just
don't feel like center left is a mischaracterization of Hutch
by Kyle, right? I can understand why Kyle would say that. I understand
why Kyle would think that. Doesn't he not like Mani? He doesn't
Well, I think he says he doesn't like Mumani in terms of optics
for the party. I think that's more of what that is. And also,
the center left thing is just such a small mischaracterization
versus the mischaracterization that that Hutch's editor, I guess,
did to Kyle because I'm critical of the left
at a time when Donald Trump is president
because he represents now a fascist threat and he has power and
he's doing these awful things. I think quite frankly is pretty
rich coming from Kyle
That is rich. Did he even endorse Kamla in 2024?
>> Hold on. Hold on.
That That feels like the biggest grasp I've ever seen in my entire
life. He's like praying he's praying that because Kyle is like
lefty, kind of hangs out with some more socialist types, he would
have been like Kamla on the Gaza issue, right? He's absolutely
praying. He just threw up a Hail Mary. All right. Except the
Hail Mary went five yards and was picked off by a defensive lineman.
All right. He just he just wound up used all of his arm strength.
Five yards downfield picked off by a D lineman. Okay. Nothing.
That was horrible. That was a horrible attempt.
>> I want to be fair. >> Uh many people saying Kyle
explicitly endorsed Camala Harris. I believe it. Uh Kyle's always
been the kind of guy who goes, "Okay, here's what I believe and
also here's the most pragmatic solution." Right? I I feel like
Kyle's always done that. He's always gone. Yeah. I like Oh, did
he go Bernie or bust? I feel like he might have even and this
was at his most I would say extreme sort of sort of like uh he
was he was massively into Bernie, right? I don't even know if
he went Bernie or bust. He's like the quintessential Bernie bro,
but he might have even gone, you know, Trump's obviously worse
and and obviously we need um
we need Hillary to win over Trump. I feel like he still would
have said that
only one year in 2020. But was it Bernie or Bus? That's what
I'm asking you. I understand he loved Bernie. I'm saying was
he Bernie or Bus? As in if Bernie doesn't get in, I don't vote.
That's more what I'm asking. Was it Bernie gets in or I don't
vote
or I don't endorse? That's more what I'm asking. Not uh not this
one. Oh, he voted green in New York.
>> I know he didn't endorse Hillary in 2016. I know he
didn't endorse >> Okay. Okay. Okay. I was like I I knew
in 2016 it'd be rough. In 2020 it's a bit weird, but he's also
in New York. It's a bit weird to not endorse Biden in 2020. I'd
say that's actually
I I feel like there's it looks worse on you to not endorse Biden
in 2020 versus not endorsing Camala in 2024 >> or Joe Biden
in 2020. I want to be fair. Uh hold on. Let me let me see if
I can >> afterwards. He said he should have voted for Biden.
I see. I think he might have, but I know he was talking about
like he was gassing up Maryanne Williamson. I I know that. Um
he was talking about how like Mary Listen, he loves Mary and
Williamson. What can you do? This happens. This sickness happens
to many people. Okay, this love for Maryanne Williamson that's
totally like
unfathomable.
Like it's crazy. I I never get it. Some people just like it.
Okay, we win. We win with love, guys. Maryanne Williamson.
um
like the only candidate that was like
talking about Medicare for all or something like that. Um does
anybody know if he like if somebody could just tell me does anybody
know if he endorsed Kamla?
Did he suggest this to his voters that they've been looking for?
>> Could I could I paint him with the same brush? Listen,
I did a lot of work learning about Hassan. Can I just say what
I would say about Hassan but about Kyle? Guys, guys, can you
figure out how I can just say the same things I said about Hassan,
but about Kyle Kolinsky? I don't I don't really want to work
that hard today. I just like to say the same things I said about
Hassan. About Kyle Kolinsky. Can you guys work that out for me?
I just I don't know, man. Oh, I'm going to sleep. I'm going to
sleep.
you got to go to people's Twitter feeds and then uh like do searches
for certain words. And sometimes you can't. Uh >> is this
even coming through?
Oh, I'm soaring into my micare my bare case for Kla middle of
the road most likely bull Trump ran a horrible campaign. Um,
I was convinced
worst case scenario for Kla was 276 electoral college votes.
I was dead wrong. Trump has done it again.
I don't So like he seemed um he seemed like he was kind of gassing
her up. So maybe I mean maybe he did maybe he did in 2024.
Um, he endor he endorsed Jill Stein.
Man, has anybody run the hypothetical? It's like totally useless.
But would it have been better for Trump to just get into office
again? Like if he had just won the 2020 election, isn't that
like an infinitely better timeline,
right? He doesn't get all the time to sit outside of office and
see about like lawsuits and do January 6th. If he just gets in
again, he just kind of runs the same ineffective playbook and
then leaves. I think like it's actually the worst case scenario
that he loses 2020, he gets back into 2024. That's that's up
to think about.
>> He doesn't literally say the word endorse, but he made
it clear over and over that he wanted her to win. It does look
like that. Um, but he I just can't find if he ever came out and
said like, "Yes, you should you should do it. You should uh you
should vote for her." Um,
so like in September, he said after after the debate,
the Kamla campaign should unleash Tim Walls.
They endorsed Stein, but was that before? >> Uh, he endorsed
Stein. Yes. Before it was down to Camala and Trump, I believe
he he eventually
uh says strategically you should vote for Kamala uh Kamala to
his audience. One second. I'll be right back. Was that before
Biden dropped out? Um, thank you Crystal Ball and Kyle Kolinsky
for your coveted endorsements of Jill Stein.
What? How do you see what the exact date of this post is? Because
it just says one year ago. If I search for his If I search this
for Stein, what am I going to find? I don't know if he endorsed
them. Did he ask chat GPT? You know what? You know what? I think
I just might. You hover over the date on the post. Well, it just
says one year ago. So, oh, hold on. Uh May 12th, 2024. Let me
let me just say that this is this is Hutch desperately like um
sorry, desperately grasping for a W, right? He's he's desperately
grasping for a W, trying to go, well, maybe I could prove that
Kyle's actually the hypocrite if he didn't endorse Camala Harris.
I Why isn't he engaging with the fact that his editor has essentially
has effectively lied about Kyle, right?
and that his response to that was, "Well, technically Kyle lied
about me because he said one of our debates that was very civil
was quote unquote heated."
Isn't that a lie? Isn't that kind of the same thing? Maybe that
changed after Kamla took over. Um, did Kyle Kolinsky ever publicly
endorse Kla Harris? Same with like Crystal Ball, did she? I I
know that they I I think both of them were definitely not about
um Biden, but I think that might have changed when Kamla took
over. Any which
I just find it rich because my record is
consistent about endorsing Democrats and meaningfully opposing
>> Oh, yeah, dude. One >> meaningfully opposing Republicans.
I am so consistent, you guys. Like, I'm so consist like Anybody
who's been tuning into my stream for years, it's the same [__]
bro. In terms of electoral politics,
I have always
always
my position
has always been the Republican party has grown completely out
of control.
They have been dangerous in my opinion for decades. I I've always
been consistent on my positions.
Okay, so what Hutch said or sorry, what Kyle said was he punches
left all the time, right? And he's like center left and he lied
about me in his thumbnail. Hutch is now going, "Guys, I really
don't like Republicans." And
did this guy even endorse Kamla?
How is that a response? I don't What is Who does he think he's
responding to? He's like made up things to respond to. What is
happening? My political awakening was forged in the fires of
George W. Bush's
war in Iraq. And so just for years, I've been primed in that
way. But especially after Donald Trump became the leader of the
Republican party, I have consistently in every single election
been telling my audience that this is a
Crazy Gaming XL. This has nothing to do with this point though.
Hutch, please respond to Geiohound in chat. Oh, hold on. What
was Geio Hound saying? What did Geio Hound say? We get a Geio
Hound comment somewhere in here that I could see. Oh, right here.
Hutch, genuine question. You've mentioned you found medication
very helpful for your bipolar disorder. Oh, well,
>> I thought it was going to be about politics, man. >> Like,
anybody who's been tuning into my stream for years has always
been the Republican party has grown completely out of control.
They have been dangerous in my opinion for decades. >> How
many other people could we have? >> And so just for years
I've been primed in that way. But especially after Donald Trump
became the leader of the Republican party, I have consist
>> been telling my audience that
>> this is a problem. The like Donald Trump is uniquely
dangerous.
I don't care how you feel about this or that Democrat. Now is
not the time to [__] around. Like that's just been
my message the whole time. And so I don't know. I don't know
if uh Kyle changed. >> I mean that's not the message I
see him. Hold on. Maybe that maybe that is consistently his message.
You know what? I don't like follow Hutch that closely. Maybe
he just tweets an unfathomable Yeah. But unfathomable amount.
Let's see.
This is his Twitter stream. Uh unfathomably incompetent. This
is the Lindsy Halagan stuff, right? Yeah. Lindsay Hagan stuff.
We'll be looking at
No idea what socialism is. So focused on the left response to
Hassan focused on Mum Dani. Uh pot and kettle situation.
So is there anything literally anything a Dem candidate can say
that would cause his fellow Dems to say that's too much. You
need to drop out. Oh, this is a tacky Ted Cruz. Let's go W.
Talk about Kyle and all these people on the left. Okay. Why am
I being asked to so focus solely on Trump from viewers who are
defending creators that I critique who blame Dems for everything
that Trump does? Wait, this was yesterday. Wait, do you feel
like Kyle blames Dems for everything Trump does? Well, that actually
might be true. I'm trying to think. He He does get mad at how
weak Dems are, but it's not like he thinks the beliefs are bad.
He's saying I think the the politicians are
He's not necessarily bad. Okay,
looking through a little bit. It's like it's like 50/50.
Okay, we can go back. I still have a lot of focus on on leftists
and stuff. which is his opinion about um this race after Kamla
took over. It kind of looks like he did, but uh even this to
me is bad. So like in May of 2024, if he changed his mind, okay,
fine. You know,
that's good. I guess if he did change his mind and endorse Kamla,
but in May
>> of 2024 and you're endorsing Jill Stein, I I just, you
know, >> dude, he actually he actually runs it back to
Oh, but like during um when when it was Joe Biden, okay, you
you endorsed Jill Stein? Really, Kyle? Really, Kyle? Were you
were like trying to get Jill Stein like some some fundraising
money because she's somebody you think is like a good politician
and advocates for good things? Really, Kyle? really Kyle.
>> And so for someone like look, he's I think he's clearly
evolved at least somewhat. Um >> 100%. Let's talk about
this because our man Kyle, we love both, man. I love growth.
And I love to see people who change their minds to agree with
us. >> Wait, did uh I feel like Kyle might have easily
been like, "Oh, Joe's going to win this easily. I'm going to
endorse Jill Stein." And then he watched Joe Biden's brain melt
out through his ears and was like, "Oh, I probably need to endorse
whoever's on the damn side because we're every once in a while.
I get to feel like maybe we had a little bit to do with that.
I don't think we had a lot to do with it this time. I think mostly
the, you know, the horrible horrible horrible horrible things
happening in Palestine had most of what do I think we already
kind of, you know, we already we already kind of softened the
runway a little bit. We were like, you know what, Kyle, here's
why we think Joe Biden >> Oh, I actually forgot about how
heavily October 7th was weighing into this as well. Like the
response to October 7th and how Joe Biden had no response. He
could not do anything to restrain Israel's response to to the
October 7th >> Sucks. He was like, "No, I'm a Biden bro
now. I'm really into this guy. You know, he's he's exceeded my
expectations across the board." And we were like, "Yo, he's going
to let you down. Just don't trust him. I know, you know, things
are looking, you know, not as bad as they could have been. But
don't worry, he's a Democrat. He is going to show you his stripes,
bro. He's going to he's going to it all up. He's going to do
something horrible. Uh, you know, let's just let's just collect
ourselves." And then finally either Kyle came around like I think
those are. >> So now now by the way we're now we're going
from attacking Kyle's claims and realizing Hutch was wrong to
attacking Kyle's position on Camala and realizing Hutch was wrong
to kind of talking about Crystal's position maybe and realizing
that would be to going to the Vanguard's characterization of
Kyle's position so that he could attack the Vanguard. He keeps
having to go to more and more hated opponents of his own stream
to look less.
Am I the only person seeing this progression slowly happen?
Like, oh, maybe if I I'm I'm thinking I don't think we'll get
there because it's really jumping the shark. But there's no possible
way
in the world that he could end up on a Hassan stream, right?
Talking about Kyle Kolinsky. I don't think so. This has to be
the anything past this and I start thinking that this is like
a bit and and Hutch is just playing a caricature
character. A character. Did they actually show a clip of Crystal
and Kyle endorsed Jill Stein? Whatever. You know, we're drawing
this out, but I I you know, I'm making the point that it's like,
bro, I have been so consistent. Was Was Kyle's criticism? Hutch,
you're not consistent. Was that Kyle's criticism? Was that what
Kyle said about
Hey, the thing I don't like about Hutch is he's not consistent,
guys.
Who said that? Who said that anywhere? Al Banjo Twitch, thank
you so much for the primer.
Okay, lol with uh I think I already got you for that one. The
real Jesse Heyman,
the name. That's a that's a name right there. Um, bro, he's like
it's this is an example of the opposite of the Andrew Wilson
effect. Okay, this is why you'll hear Rob laugh and and Andrew
Wilson laugh is because this is like demotivating for your own
audience. when you're like this caught off guard, this speechless,
you have nothing you could possibly say. You just look like you've
just been going through cope and like slowly getting like slowly
owning yourself and then you're totally demotivated and you're
just like silent. This is why other people work on the the what
do you call it the bravado thing where they laugh and they think
they're correct all the time because otherwise you end up looking
like this where you're just like totally incorrect. You're totally
owned and you're just like slowly waiting your way through the
>> Sorry, I'm getting a little stunt stun locked by chat
there. Um
I like look I I I have been saying um pretty consistently recently
>> as bad as bad >> that I think Kyle is like the
very definition of a mixed bag.
okay I don't understand. So Kyle's complaint again is you lied
about one of my core tenants, one of my core positions or your
editor did via the thumbnail and title combination. you lied
about me. I feel like that was very
And now Hutch is like, well, Kyle's a mixed bag. Are did he forget
that he was responding to Kyle's accusations,
but there's a lot of stuff that I find just
I don't know if the word is disappointing or um I just think
like what was the most thing we uh covered? So, there was the
video that we watched >> show Hutch and Kyle as seen in
the attached image in a slap fight. >> That's pretty good.
What the um I you know I think Kyle is like a content machine
and unfortunately I think he focuses more on output rather than
like solid analysis
>> again. Uh Kyle Kyle's kind of not reliable. Just respond
to what he said, bro. Or at least admit you him admit something.
Um, but but I've also seen like the clip of him taking Briana
Joy Gray to task
I think is a really good clip from him, you know. Um, but we
watched this was like a couple weeks ago, like three two or three
weeks ago, but he was covering like the conspiracy theory stuff
and it just like a lot of that was just straight up brain rot.
Like I don't know what it was. It was just brain rot, you
Did Kyle get really mad that you laughed at his takes on the
Charlie Kirk stuff? Did Kyle say anything about that? Did Kyle
complain? Did he say anything? Are you just going to a totally
adjacent issue? Uh, sorry, a totally not even adjacent, a totally
like perpendicular issue. Parallel, maybe it doesn't cross parallel
issue that isn't even something Kyle raised. You're going to
something he doesn't didn't talk about, didn't complain about
and pretending that that applies to now.
Kyle, for all you know, goes when he when he sees that thumbnail,
he goes, "Ah, well, that's fair." Yeah, it was kind of Yeah,
I was kind of just rolling with it. I was kind of just vibing.
>> He was entertaining some conspiracy theories about Charlie
Kirk that I thought, you know, there's really only two ways to
explain this and they're both bad.
The first way is that it's just clickbait. Like he So, he's totally
sidestepped the actual complaint, the actual criticism from Kyle
and gone on to talk about other bad things Kyle has done.
Guys, don't you remember how unreliable Kyle is? Guys, don't
you remember that Kyle like sucks? Kyle lies. Kyle's a total
piece of [__] actually. Oh, but we had like a we
have a respectable relationship. I'm not trying to mislead you
about him. Kyle's just kind of a piece of Okay, I Dude, this
guy cannot pick Elaine. >> Knew that anything in >> Do
you remember at the very beginning of this, we started watching
this and I'm like, Hutch wants to stand up business to say Kyle's
a piece of but he's like too scared to do it. He doesn't want
to upset the guy and he's just he's just like waffled back and
forth across this line the whole time being unable to pick what
he's doing here. Just say Kyle sucks. Well, now he's kind of
saying it, but say Kyle sucks and you do believe he thinks Republicans
and Democrats are the same. They're all politicians. They all
suck. Stand stand up business, man. Involving kind of like Charlie
Kirk and, you know, assassinated and conspiracy. And he knew
that those those videos were going to just do numbers, which
they did. They got like I think over a million views.
He did two videos on conspiracy theories and they both collectively
I think got like three three million views. Um
so I think that's bad because I think as a creator if you're
covering politics
you should definitely not lean into conspiracy brain rot because
you think the videos are going to do numbers. Like I personally
feel that
I know a lot of people have argued to me, right, that the Kyle
Klinsky videos were just satire. I don't know if they were all
satire. I do know a couple of them he was like goofing around
with. Like when he got into the more absurd ones, he was clearly
goofing around. With some of the less absurd ones, some of the
ones that are like at least maybe defensible in some universe,
right? Even though there wasn't a lot of evidence, it's like
at least believing this doesn't make you like totally disconnected
from reality. I felt like he was I felt like he was on >> The
American electorate has become
conspiratorial in a way that I think is quite damaging. >> Uh
we all agree the Kirk stuff has some legit questions to be asked,
right? Um not really. Not really. All I've ever seen about the
Kirk stuff that seems like weird is basically Candace Owens looking
at the text messages and going, "Well, that's that's not how
people text. People don't say those words." I mean, if you if
you believe that the FBI straight up lied to pretend that that
guy's the shooter and he had nothing to do with it,
maybe. As far as like Charlie Kirk was shot by like an random
independent actor, I don't think there's anything that shows
that that didn't happen. I don't think there's any reason to
believe he was shot by somebody other than who they said. I don't
know about you guys, but I think that the tendency towards conspiracy
theories now,
it's just really bad. It's like really destructive. It's one
of the things that I think causes a lot of people to lose faith
in, you know, our our system and and uh our institutions.
Bad. It's destructive.
Really bad. >> Wow. Wow. I think we can all agree that
conspiracy brain has kind of ruined some things, right, guys?
Let's totally forget about whatever Kyle was saying. Aren't conspiracies
bad, guys? Aren't conspiracies really, really bad,
guys? Can we all agree that conspiracies
>> Really bad. Um, >> uh, has Hutch said anything
in the past 20 minutes? He has. It's just, Listen, I'm hoping
that he recovers and realizes that he was responding to something
at the beginning of this and just trailed off into something
totally unrelated. >> I think it's horrible. I think it's
horrible.
It used to be that conspiracy theorists were kind of relegated
to the fringes. There was a movie in the 90s
starring Mel Gibson and Julia Roberts called Conspiracy Theory
and the main character is Mel Gibson and he's this conspiracy
theorist and everybody dismisses him as a kook
but he ends up being right. Dude, what
what is he saying?
Guys, there's a movie from the '9s.
Oh, I he I swear to God in his head he's like, "Okay, I've said
enough. I've I've babbled totally inanely for long enough that
everybody's like totally mentally reset. They don't remember
what we were talking about. I could just about go back to watching
this video going like, I don't even remember what we were talking
about, guys." And then we can move on
about one of those conspiracy theories. And then it turns into
like a a thriller. But the point was like that's how conspiracy
theorists were portrayed in media. That's how they were spoken
about. We had these crazy tabloids that do they even exist anymore?
But like we >> Dude, I'm sorry. I I'm now committed to
speeding this up slightly and waiting until he gets back to whatever
actual conversation he was having and him just seeing that he
won't resolve it cuz there's no way he's going to resolve it,
right? It's just not possible at this point. I feel like he's
totally forgotten what he was talking about. I just want to watch
the end so I can see it. Growing up, you would go to the grocery
store with your parents and you know, dude, there could be a
crazy edit on this. That dude, how did he get to without talking
about what Kyle said? Dude, Kyle has to react to this, right?
Could you imagine a Kyle Kolinsky reaction where he gives a clear,
concise criticism, and Hutch copes copes copes, changes the topic,
copes, copes, copes, changes the topic, gets totally onto something
unrelated, then then he's eventually just talking about his him
growing up. Guys, do you remember growing up? Do you do you guys
remember what do you guys remember when it was like this? Do
you guys remember >> a 10-minute grocery store trip would
felt like it was like three and a half hours to a seven-year-old
and then you go to the checkout area and there these magazines
and then the magazine it's like a bat boy discovered in New Jersey
and it's this you know picture of like a half bat half boy and
uh people you know generally thought that those people were insane
and uh we kind of laughed at people like that or at least I feel
like that's how culturally that's how like it was portrayed in
the arts and the media you know and now it's just so mainstream
you know it's a huge percentage of the country just fully believes
in conspira theories and uh it's just it's just doing a lot of
damage so if you're if you're clickbing on conspira theories
because you think it's going to make a lot of money I think that's
bad. I don't think I think that's really bad. You're just like
a You're a merchant of chaos, I guess. You know, you're selling
>> Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. A lot of money.
>> You're a what? >> I think that's really bad. I
don't tell you. I think that's just really bad. You're just like
a You're a merchant of
a merchant with his hands pressed together like this.
Didn't Didn't Hutch recently get on Anakasparian for this exact
thing? Am I I'm obviously making something. It's fine. Chaos,
I guess. you know, you're selling product viewers product is
just chaos. You know, you're just leaning into it. >> And
then the other thing to explain it would be that he legitimately
was open to these conspiracy theories, which were insane. He
was lending credence to like, you know, when you look at the
video, you can't explain how like so I guess for this to make
any sense, for this to be a logical progression of thoughts.
Hutch has to think, well, Kyle Kolinsky kind of entertained Charlie
Kirk conspiracies, so me lying about him isn't a problem because
Kyle Kolinsky, me harming him, me harming his reputation by lying
about him by being misleading about him is okay because Kyle
Kolinsky entertains conspiracy theories and so I'm only harming
somebody who is already harmful. Otherwise, this is unrelated
and it's inane psycho babble. Okay, that's the only case in which
this is a relevant story. Kyle can't Kyle can't complain cuz
he entertains conspiracy theories about Charlie Kirk. So I get
to lie about him. Look the color of that column right there.
And then look what happens when he jumps down. You can't explain
that. There's a person walking in the background. Where did that
person go? Like that stuff is just, you know, so that to me is
like a pretty kind of a pretty big deal, right? And then like
we covered a video of his last week. There's a video up on uh
up on the channel. It's actually the last video that I uploaded
um where he's talking about Obama and just I you know I just
you know I think some I say he's a mixed bad but like I think
it's like mostly bad for me. I don't like to me like after the
election it was like oh it seems like he's on a different path
now seems like he's evol dude instead of instead of taking any
responsibility here we have copded our way into well Kyle kind
of sucks so you know what him actually oh yeah I did forget that
I said him oh yeah you're right oh my god I did forget that I
kind of said burn the bridge well yeah Hutch does actually sorry
Kyle does actually suck >> evolved but it's like you don't
get to
you don't get to evolve after Donald Trump ascends to power for
a second time
and then use that evolution as a kind of like shield
against criticism. It's like, bro, you have been spending the
last several years, your maybe your entire career doing this
whole like dem's bad flowchart stuff in Oh, so it's like I don't
care about what your position is now or how your position's been
nuanced. You've said Dems's bad for a long time. I'm referring
to you in the past.
Oh,
okay. Well, that's actually another just totally that's unrelated
to any of the psycho babble. We could have just gone straight
there,
right? We could have just gone straight there. Well, before this,
I feel like you kind of compared Democrats and Republicans and
said the establishment people suck. So, I'm I'm actually referring
to that.
That's if you want to make that argument, why didn't he just
make that argument from the beginning? Why did he make us suffer
through all of that insane cope that was totally unrelated to
anything Kyle was >> Insane false equivalences. You know,
he was on Joe Rogan's podcast the night of the election in 2020
and Rogan asked him if he voted for Biden and he said, "No, I
don't vote for war criminals." I just want you to think about
that for a second. This was after 4 years of Trump. Huh? I can't
listen. I can't attack Kyle's current opinions. I can't represent
Kyle accurately now because I'm so apt pained about 2020 and
Kyle's positions in 2020 that I will never let them go and I
will always use them to attack him. And even if you think even
if it looks like I'm making a modern critique, a current critique,
I'm actually just referring to 2020 Kyle Kitsky. So checkmate,
Kyle. You can't change the past. Get a time machine if you want
me to stop saying that you make Republicans and Democrats equal
that you you compare them. You think they're equal. Okay, [__]
you. This was after co
with Trump 2020 with Trump as president. And because of Donald
Trump's faulty
people estimate that perhaps hundreds of thousands of people
died that maybe wouldn't have died if there was a competent president
sitting in there. After all that, after 40 Charlottesville and
Helsinki and firing Comey, two impeachments and or I guess at
the time it was one impeachment. >> Are we going back to
now 2020 was also Kyle's fault or sorry, 2016 was also Kyle's
fault. Okay. >> He says, "No, no, no. I don't vote for
war criminals." It's like, "Okay, I'm glad that you've evolved."
And you say stuff like you would vote for Joe Mansion in 2028
if he was the nominee. But some of us have been some of us have
been getting the homework. Dude, there's
Oh my god.
Well, I understand that you have the right positions now, but
I've been correct the whole time. So, when I lie about what you
think, okay, you just have to take it, Kyle, cuz I'm just better
than you. I'm better than you. I'm built different than you.
Some of us have been getting it right the whole time, Kyle. Some
of us have been getting it right the entire time. And you're
you're just a [__] And I get to say whatever I want
about you now, Kyle. you some of us have been doing the homework
for years. All right. So I I mean I guess it's fair to complain
about the thumbnail, but I I really thought like he was fine
with clickbait because that's what we spoke about privately.
He said, you know, like so now it's just clickbait again. Now
it's not a real criticism that is valid because of 2020.
>> it's YouTube, bro. You know, had to clickbait it a little
bit. Like >> again, he's saying so Hutch has already himself
said by his own standard this isn't clickbait, right? Because
Hutch said if it if it's totally misleading, it has nothing to
do with the actual content of the video. That is not clickbait.
That's that's misleading. And he doesn't do that. I I it's rare
to see somebody like this. Somebody who's like that inconsistent
within the same >> Yeah, about that. I suppose >> any
awareness round people up and put them in concentration >> and
then they do this thing where it's >> I know I said I wasn't
going to do the punching left thing, but uh I just can't get
over just I I just can't get over it. You know, like Donald Trump
is president. He's doing these awful things. Therefore, you shouldn't
punch left. It's like, isn't that convenient? You know, like,
weren't you saying don't >> Wait, why can't Okay, >> punch
left before >> I just just a little bit in my head. I'm
like, wait, was wasn't Hutch also punching left? Was he punching
left? Maybe not. Hold on. I don't know. Does he understand what
he's saying? Yes. So, I think Captain C319, I think we're going
the same direction here where I'm like, "Wait, then what was
your problem with Kyle punching left when it came to like Democrats
and their position on Israel
where they have like this this actual principal position on Israel?
They're really upset about it. Kyle has this this position, right?"
What was your problem with punching left and saying that this
isn't acceptable,
especially when he actually endorsed Kamala Harris? Donald Trump
was even
and now you think that you can use Donald Trump as a shield from
critique. Like what planet do you live on?
What? Something that I think like people like Kyle Kolinsky contributed
to over the years,
these insane equivocations, this this Green Lantern setting impossible
standards for the Democratic party and then, you know, telling
your audience that the Democratic Party is almost as evil as
the Republican party because they don't meet your impossible
in inventing these narratives about people like Barack Obama
that he didn't actually care about expanding healthcare coverage,
like just tearing down the Democratic party every chance you
get,
which I think helped Donald Trump win this election.
Which direction does people like Hassan punch when they Biden
for four years? Well, I think technically in the the traditional
leftright spectrum, they'd be punching right. Now, you could
argue don't punch within your own coalition coalition, which
is fine, too. But that would be punching right technically.
>> And then when he wins the election and becomes president,
now you turn around and say, well, you shouldn't criticize me
because he's president and you got to keep your eye on him. >> Again,
Kyle has never said here anywhere, don't criticize me, right?
He said you're kind of like Destiny and that you spend a lot
of time punching left and that you lied about him.
So, you're saying I do punch left. You agree with that. And now
and then and then you agree with oh well it's clickbait or but
you watched it you had no no comeback to oh it's like incredibly
misleading is obviously taking a position he has which is don't
um the position Kyle has is Republicans Democrats can't be compared.
They are not equal. Don't don't try to equate them. And you made
it seem like he equates them all the time. Those were Kyle's
two criticisms and Hutch has just basically agreed. He's basically
said Kyle's right but somehow still makes this face for the thumbnail
so they could say Kyle Klinsky is out of his mind. That's just
amazing logic to me, you know? That's just amazing logic. Like
I I genuinely believe that people like Kyle helped to create
the conditions for Donald Trump to win. Like I genuinely believe
that. And so to then turn around and then use Donald Trump as
a shield. It's just like come on. Like are you kidding me? Do
you really think that people shouldn't criticize you? The whole
concept of punching left is just so silly. It is bananas. Maybe
it's the frequent you are so dishonest. I don't think I am a
dishonest person person.
You can say a lot of things about me. You can criticize me on
on many fronts and the stream chat. >> I don't know. Like,
oh man, this is tough. Is he like intentionally being dishonest
or is he totally like incapable? Is he like a goldfish? That's
That's the question. We run into this a lot. All right.
I don't think I am a dishonest person.
I genuinely endeavor to be truthful. I make an effort to be truthful.
Uh Dazani with $2.
What war crimes did Biden commit prior to 2020?
Who knows? I I think he, you know, anybody who supported the
war in Iraq,
I think was probably his logic there would would be accurate.
Crystal is worse, but she is corrupting Kyle. Like Aaron is corrupting
Pisco. IMO. Bro, how in the world could you think Crystal is
corrupting Kyle?
Kyle is the original Bernie, bro. He's the original. Like, they
stole the election for Bernie. You have to you have to fight
the system now. You have to burn it down. That's Kyle. That's
who Kyle Klinsky is. That's his That's the bones of his career.
What do you mean crystal corrupted Kyle? Are we serious? Oh,
and like Aaron is corrupting Pisco. Do we? Again, I think I pointed
this out before. It's just so It must be so insulting for Joanne,
the the silly serious, right? That she's like a super far leftist.
She's super progressive, right? She spends every day with Pisco.
She's actually Pisco's partner. And then people go, "Aaron's
corrupting Pisco when they talk like three times a week tops."
Like if anybody's corrupting Pisco, don't you wouldn't you have
to say it's Joe? It would have to be the silly series. By the
way, not possible. Pisco is way too corrupt. Okay, but if you're
going to make the argument, why wouldn't you make it with the
right female? You're not even doing misogyny well. You're failing
at overt like transparent misogyny.
The bar is so low and you you've failed to to make it accurately
described as a war criminal. But that like a war criminal, you
know, like war crimes, these these terms are very flexible. Um,
hold on. Is she on YouTube or Twitch or anything? Does she have
a channel Pisco's partner? Yes. In fact, we have a video from
her on the docket today. Hold on. Uh, we are going to watch this
video later after the Hutch segment. It's >> I've been
reading too many people >> Okay. Ma Magic Blind Politics/The
Silly Serious right here. Watch this video in a little bit. If
you guys don't remember, she had a very popular video a while
back. It's the dark gothic manga video. 2.4 million views. kind
of launched her channel with it. So, yes, his Pisco's partner
is literally a political commentator. So, the chatters who say
like this are just transparently moronic.
Sad, >> you know. I posted Kyle's endorsement of Jill Stein
in the React channel. Was this in 2024? Like, like we had the
threat we we have we had the threat of Donald Trump
>> following me right now. We have the threat of Donald
Trump, you know. >> Uh, wait. So, because Trump's president,
I can't criticize you guys.
We have the threat of Donald Trump. you wouldn't even support
the Dems no matter what. Wow. That's that's just Hutch in a nutshell,
isn't it?
So, I feel like most people on this are just like, "Yeah, you
probably should have been scared of Trump and voted blue no matter
who in the election." And now you should probably be to some
extent blue no matter who. Now, now not no matter who, but like
you you want to move forward with the strongest Democratic party
you can, right? So, if your criticisms are here's what I think
is wrong with these people and here's how we make the the Democratic
party better, that's fine. and you spend a lot of time focusing
on how awful Trump is. That's also good.
I don't know. I just I feel like probably in both cases, you
should have been voting for the the Democratic candidate.
>> The second Donald Trump presidency and he's over here
endorsing Jill Stein over Joe Biden >> and so >> Oh
no. Oh no. He almost had he almost saved himself.
Did you guys see it? He almost saved himself earlier when this
came up and they were talking about Kyle endorsing Jill Stein.
He was like, "Oh, wait. When was that though? Was Biden still
president? He almost saved himself and now he's getting linked
to clip and now he's just leaning into it. Oh, you you're going
to endorse Jill Stein when when there's Donald Trump. >> Energizing
to see people like uh Crystal Ball and Kyle Kolinsky uh giving
their endorsement uh to our work together here to put an end
to genocide. So, I'm not sure who is going to switch us to that
>> That is [__] amazing.
framing an endorsement for Jill Stein as doing work to end a
genocide. Like what what what work are you doing by doing this?
Like what are you what >> video? Okay, here we go. Thank
you, >> Hey guys, it's Kyle Klinsky here from the Kyle
Klinsky Show and Secular Talk on YouTube and also Crystal Kylin
friends. I want to wish Jill Stein a very, very happy birthday.
I'm sorry that I couldn't be there with you tonight. Uh but I
wanted to lend a message of support. So, we had her, by the way,
this this endorsement of Jill Stein before they'd switched candidates
and and the polling tightened massively, right before that all
happened. Sorry. Oh, because that happened, Hutch does just get
to be super misleading about Kyle's positions now. And Kyle doesn't
get to complain about it. And if Kyle complains about it, Pisco
is going to or sorry, Hutch is going to point out that Kyle entertained
conspiracy theories. Therefore, your opinion is invalid. >> Her
on the show the other day, and she really opened my eyes to a
number of very disturbing things. First of all, to show you how
terrible mainstream media is and how much they bury stories.
I hadn't even heard of the fact that Jill Stein was assaulted
at a prop palestine protest and then cops have the nerve to charge
her with assault. This is a presidential candidate and a woman
who's over the age of 70 >> and they're really so extreme
and so >> I I don't need to watch this. I need to watch
all this
>> crypto his own supporters. Like we're like it's here.
It's here. The ICE agents are assaulting elderly couples. What
are we doing each other? What are we doing? And like for us for
me to sit down with him and have a naval gazing conversation
about, oh, we're interleft fighting and I think you're right
about this and wrong about this. It's like, what's the point?
If you go look at my channel, my guns are pointed squarely at
the right. >> I mean, that's just over >> 90 to 95%
of my videos are going after
>> squarely at the right. >> I mean, that's just
over >> 90 to 95%.
>> Look at my channel. My guns are pointed squarely at
the right. Hold on. Maybe I'll be able to lipre. I mean, that's
90 to 95% of my videos are going after the fascist for being
fascist. >> That doesn't that doesn't mean that nobody
should criticize you. Like, what what universe do you live in?
What planet do you live on? Why would anybody agree to these
terms? Why I mean it's just to me it's like so childish, you
know? Like the whole thing is just so childish. Like sorry, you
are accountable for the things that you say. You know what I
mean? Like if you >> Dude, I
Okay, apparently Hutch is accountable for the things he says.
Dude, you get cut. You can cut together an amazing set of clips
out of this. Okay, this is actually hilarious. You're accountable
for the things you say. Well, I I don't I don't mislead. I'm
not misleading with the thumbnails. Oh, wait. Well, my editor
does do stuff sometimes, but I don't think we've ever done anything.
Oh, he did totally misrepresent him in the thumbnail. Okay. Well,
uh, have you thought about how this guy like kind of echoed some
Candace Owen sentiments in the Charlie Kirk assassination? Let
me tell Let me tell you, Kyle, you're responsible for the [__]
that comes out of your mouth. >> Wow. you say something
that is kind of silly or something that I think is >> Oh,
also I'm going to spend 40 minutes looking for your endorsement
of Jill Stein so I can say you didn't endorse Kamala Harris.
And then when I find out you did endorse Kamala Harris, I'm going
to say you didn't do it fast enough. And then when I find out
that you probably did it at a somewhat appropriate time or you
did it for sure, okay, then I'm going to say that well in 2020
and 2016 you didn't endorse the damn candidate and you're a piece
of [__] for comparing Republicans to Democrats in
2016 and 2020. [__] you, Kyle. destructive and harmful
or erroneous. This idea that nobody should criticize you now
because Donald especially after just the years and years and
years that Kyle spent
contributing to an online climate of
I don't even what's the word for like not properly evaluating
the risk of something like what's the word for like not accurately
conveying the severity of a situation? There's got to be a word
for that. Thundes
dereliction of duty. I don't know about dereliction, but there's
got to be a word for this. Carelessness, negligent
hiding his power level like Hassan does. He is just as illiberal.
Illiberal.
Dude, listen. I'm starting to get to the point where it's like
um derangement about Hassan. And I say derangement as in like
if you're just upset about Hassan, you bring up when it's unrelated.
That's starting to be a better heristic of like just total than
almost anything else in these spheres. And not because Hassan
isn't worthy of criticism or doesn't do stupid all the time or
say stupid all the time. I just I noticed that people like focus
on this guy because it's it feels so profitable
with like no real they just they can't see what the actual problems
are.
Like they they're focused on Ka, right?
I could totally I don't even have to defend Hassan's conduct.
Hassan's conduct uh I don't have to defend at all. I could just
go well I look at the people who are criticizing him and I see
like their opinions on things. They watch a segment like this
and they're like, "Well, Kyle's just kind of like Hassan, isn't
he?" It's just used as a It's almost like comparisons to Hassan
for Hutch's community are like comparisons in other communities.
Like, this guy's a and it's that total like uh none of your normal
processing goes and evaluates the statement. They're just like, "Oh,
I heard the word. I can dis I can totally uh what do you call
totally dismiss this person now?" It's like the same thing here.
It's like Kyle's kind of like Hassan, isn't he? And then people's
brains can just shut off. Oh, he's like Hassan. Oh, we don't
have to think about it anymore. Oh, he's he's bad. He's really
bad, guys. >> And being reckless. I think reckless is a
good I think reckless is a good word. Yeah, I think reckless
is a good word for it.
Just years of that. And you know, now he does a quasi about face
and you know, he's focused on Donald Trump. It's like, okay,
that's great, but whatever. Anyways,
so does Hutch not have any concept at all? Thought termination
is exactly what I was looking for. Thank you. Blackbeard gayest
blouse. Blackbeard's gayest blouse. Thank you very much. Yes,
thought termination. It's thought terminating. Um, thank you.
That was the word I was looking for. So, hold on. I got to back
it up. I was just about to respond to Kyle and then I saw that
comment that was, >> you know, he's focused on Donald Trump.
It's like, >> oh, right. Kyle says, sorry, Hutch says
that Kyle's quasi aboutfaced.
That's that's called Kyle is now on your side. Right. Kyle is
on your side and you don't want to give him credit for that.
Doesn't that seem concerning that if you convince people and
that you're just always going to hold their old position against
them, aren't you concerned for like the the knock-on effects
of that that you have to hold their old positions against them
to criticize them now to punch left, so to speak? It just seems
seems a little concerning to me, right? Oh, Kyle. Yeah, Kyle's
totally like on our side now. He's like totally on the on the
on the same page as us. He's on the right side. But, you know,
2020 and 2016 loom large. All right. He he built the culture.
We got to get him. >> Okay, that's great. But whatever.
Anyways, it's not Kyle's not all bad, but like I just there are
certainly worse commentators out there. But in my in my opinion,
he still has a long way to go before um
I just, you know, he would have to really fundamentally change,
I think. Um because I think he just has has a tend tendency to
um like that video of him talking about Obama just blew my mind.
Like it really just blew my mind. you know, he really does exist
in a kind of um fabricated universe where he genuinely believes
that presidents and political parties can basically do there's
there's always a way to do something like I just like I just
realized from Hutch has made me realize that when I'm evaluating
a segment like this, when it's one content creator fighting with
another, what I need to do every time is pop notepad open and
write down the first person's criticism and then track how the
response actually addresses any of the criticism because this
has just been a like maybe possibly like a masterclass in obfiscation,
right? He has not answered anything Kyle said. He's not really
made any tangible attempt to to like rectify the problem here,
which is obviously his editor is doing stuff doing stuff and
saying things that he doesn't stand by or stand behind at all.
Right. And he doesn't want to just say that. He doesn't want
to say, "Well, no, no, no, I don't think that about Kyle." He's
like, "Oh, well, did what happened here exactly?" He's like trying
to go through it and figure out how he can how he can still hate
Kyle after this. Right. Oh, well, did he did he endorse Camala?
So, we need to track along when when it's creator on creator
violence, we need to track the original claim, the criticism,
and see how the response matches up cuz holy, if there's anything
that you want to do, like there's always a way to do it. You
just have to be like creative enough or forceful enough or charismatic
enough
and he's got all the answers.
Like, if only the Democratic party would listen to people like
Kyle Kolinsky, we would have like an 80 seat majority in the
Senate. And it's just always just such a it just feels like such
I don't know if lowhanging fruit is the right word that I'm thinking
of in my mind, but it's just that's the easiest job in the universe.
Are you kidding me? Armchair quarterbacking a political party
is the easiest job in the world. >> Cuz you don't have
to defend a track record. Like you can just sit there and just
wax poetic about them how the world would be such a better >> anybody
who only has criticisms and doesn't have positive like constructive
plans, you don't really have to listen to. Yeah, sure. place
if if they only just like listen to your sage wisdom. Why is
why is Kyle going after you when there's a genocide going on
right now? Yeah. Yeah.
>> You got a $5 donation saying, "Hey, here's some here's
some stuff from Hutch." And Kyle went, "This is what I don't
like about Hutch,
>> To be honest, this whole thing is retilting me pretty
hard. You guys need to have private conversations and get your
[__] together. I don't know what this is about, bro.
Like, uh,
me and Kyle are not friends. We've never been friends. We were
friendly for like a brief second in time, but we were never close
friends. Like what? >> I need now I I badly need Kyle Kolinsky
to go respond to this.
Where is Where is Kyle? How much do we have to donate to Kyle
Kolinsky to get him to watch this and and respond?
I need I need it. I need it. You know, what do what do you think
like political commentary is? You know, like political commentary
is very often times
reacting to other people's commentary. It's like a big public
discussion. That's that's that's the job. Like that's the work.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Kraken Robotic
is up 15% today. Is it 1.5% or 15%. Do you care? I don't I don't
know what that >> Sorry, I didn't.
>> Move Move on to Destiny. Kyle is done. All right, listen.
You're barking orders at me. Okay, fine. We'll move on to Destiny.
Let's do it. I think this was I think Destiny got mad about how
Lib and learn tree touch again. Maybe honestly I don't recall.
I didn't watch any of the segment. I didn't even look at commentary.
I just thought this was uh I was going to evaluate the Kyle Klinsky
Hutch stuff. Destiny was against Hutch. Okay. Hutch was very
annoyed. Oh, well wrecked.
Oh, Destiny Destiny mocked Hutch for being a [__]
Oh well, listen if the if the That's funny. Okay,
that's that's just funny. I do. I might want to see that eventually.
Maybe we could come back to this. We'll see. Okay, we can think
about coming back to it. Give me a second. We can think about
coming back to it. I'll get a time stamp written down, but I
kind of want to move on to some other [__] So, you
know, you know, you know.
All right. Where are we going next?
Oh, boy. I I'm going to keep the politics stuff tied together.
Okay. We're going to do go do the Lindsay Holligan stuff really
quick. And then after the after this, we will get over on Pisco's
boy. He is indeed if he's on Hutch. Hold on. There's a line where
Dusty says Hutch is in a house with rapists. Two other people
just got raped and the rap is looking at Hutch and Hutch is like
let's not upset the It was really cutting. Oh well
listen,
you can take a lot of things away from Destiny like any consideration
as a human being but what you can't take away from him is his
ability to analogize anything to Okay, he's the best in the world
at it. He can make anything like that's just that's his gift.
God gave him that gift and we can't take it away. Joe video.
We're not doing the Joe video right now. Um I want I want to
get to the rich stuff before I get off of Twitch. So we could
do You know what? I actually should go to the rich stuff now
and do it on Twitch because if I don't do it on Twitch right
now, I'm going to end up having people leave over time and then
I'm going to want to switch off of Twitch. So we're going to
have to go to the rich stuff. Okay, let's go. Rich Campbell,
come back
Hold on. I'm trying to reset my title